all right
welcome everybody to a very special
edition of the
into the impossible bot podcast in this
time of pandemic podcasting i am
likely to say i'm your fearful host i'm
no longer fearless but uh i'm feeling a
little bit more
uh fear hopeful i suppose because of
today's excitement
and today's announcement uh led in part
by one of our guests today
uh we'll introduce you to in just a
second and i have two guests today
for my first ever dual guest live stream
on the into the impossible podcast it
could be either the first experiment or
the
last experiment who knows uh but i'm
joined by mit professor
uh dr sarah seeger who is joining us
from
cambridge massachusetts where she has
been having a very busy day so first of
all i want to say thank you to sarah
i'll put you up there there you are hi
sarah hi thank you for having me thanks
for joining us yeah i mean i've really
kind of
reached out through nefarious methods
contacting people that i know know you
i won't say who but i was able to get in
touch with you and i'm so glad that we
were able to
contact each other and similarly uh
lauren
grush who's joining us from new york
city where she
is or she has been writing for the verge
for quite some time i've been a fan of
her work for many years and she's
covered many many
wonderful and fascinating announcements
throughout science and beyond
and she was introduced to me by a
previous guest on the show which is uh
sarah skulls who wrote a book called
they are already here
about the actual uh evidence or lack
thereof perhaps of
extraterrestrial life forms on earth so
lauren thank you so much for joining us
on the podcast
happy to be here so we've got so many uh
people in the chat room now it's really
fun and we'll be taking questions there
but i will use my host prerogative
to ask the very first questions uh and
first i always like to know the human
side of things before we get into the
nitty gritty nerd out details that we
will certainly devolve
into and that's sarah what does this
discovery mean to you
and and uh you know as a scientist to
make such a huge potential huge
discovery that still has to be confirmed
as you often admit
and suggest how does it feel though i
mean tell us
in reality what does the sense can you
convey it to our audience how does it
feel to make a discovery like this
well it feels amazing of course but it
also
comes with the sense of responsibility
not to over hype
the results and we just finished dinner
and one of my
teens i've got two teenage boys was
telling me he was reading all the news
and it's all hyped him
i guess it's something you know that
that he understands and can follow
yeah it's certainly there's an element
that that could that could take place
the the question is you know
scientists often are not depicted as
having normal human emotions and i'm
sure lauren
not being a scientist but communicating
with a lot of scientists the old joke i
always use this joke you know how do you
know a scientist is outgoing
when he looks at your shoes when he
talks to you uh but
but in this case i think it connects so
deeply to
the curiosity that almost everybody has
that i think it's had a lot of resonance
with lauren what's been the reaction
as a human as a journalist to make to
report on a story like this
what does it feel like well when i first
got the release and saw what was coming
our way i knew that it was going to be a
big deal
even though i know the caveats that come
with an announcement like this
like our first as a reporter our first
reaction is okay yes
but and we try and go find the people
that
will tell us okay what are the caveats
but i knew that this was going to be a
very big deal we were very prepared for
this monday
and so far it's brought a lot of you
know delight and joy
and i think people are just a lot of
people who don't follow
science or don't follow space really
hadn't thought about the possibility
that
venus of all places this kind of
hellscape of a planet
could potentially be a place that
microbes would thrive so i think
seeing that joy from people who hadn't
really considered this has been really
fun
but of course it is our duty as
journalists to be the
yes but people and i think a lot of
journalists have conveyed it very well
with this
discovery today and sarah can you walk
us through the uh nuts and bolts of the
discovery
uh in in that what what does it actually
say
it's not the discovery of actual life as
we understand it
but can you explain a little bit about
what was found and what makes this this
so special and unique
sure well what was found is the presence
of phosphine gas
at very small concentrations 20 parts
per billion
in the venous atmosphere and
specifically in the atmosphere at the
layers
where the atmosphere is not too hot not
too cold but just right for life
now phosphine is a gas it's one
phosphorus atom and three hydrogen atoms
and it really shouldn't be present in
venus's atmosphere
we find it in jupiter and saturn but
there there's
so much hydrogen and there's also deep
in their atmospheres the temperatures
and pressures needed to make phosphine
so with none of those things it really
shouldn't be in the venous atmosphere
and yeah our team exhaustively worked
through every possible
chemical scenario and didn't find any
that would explain the presence of
fasting
and so a question in the chat room we'll
cover a lot of as many as we can but uh
the quentin experiment is asking a
question
is it correct that the phosphine gas was
found at an atmospheric layer
already predicted for many years to have
life
yes well predict predicted is
maybe not quite the right right word
people have speculated that there's life
in the venus atmosphere because they
know that the temperatures
in that region are suitable for life out
of anywhere on the surface and
atmosphere it's only that one region
and looking elsewhere in the solar
system
there are perhaps there is very fairly
strong evidence
for this phosphine molecule to be
present on other planets but what makes
it
so different for venus compared to
saturn and jupiter
well venus doesn't have hydrogen it has
almost no hydrogen and venus doesn't
even though we think of it as so hot
it's not quite hot enough
or high enough pressure to produce
fasting
and uh thinking about how this was taken
immediately
i was immediately brought back and
learned you brought this in your piece
to the discovery in the mid 90s of of
byproducts of life found in martian
potentially martian
meteorite fragments in the allen land
hills of antarctica
where i've been but i've never found any
meteorites there uh life-bearing or not
what was your initial reaction when you
heard this or are there any reminiscent
things that are reminiscent of that
discovery which was announced at the
actually there's a cute connection to
carl sagan in that this was
in the movie contact uh which is the
only book that he wrote of fiction with
with andrew and his wife
who i've had on the show as well and uh
they talked about this you know they cut
in these
you know they've discovered this alien
life that jody foster's character
obtains but uh but it's really the press
conference on the front lawn of the
white house from the martian life form
alleged martian life
what did that kind of resonate with you
or how did that how did that how did you
react to that kind of
playful discovery so me and my reporter
friends we all have a joke it's actually
from
miriam cramer who's at axios now but
it's always our mantra is it's never
aliens and
we try to kind of abide by that whenever
we get big discoveries
um because there's always new
discoveries like this that are coming
out that said well
it could be another earth or it could be
this or it could be that
so it does it reminds us a lot of those
and
it wasn't just the martian meteorite
that a lot of people were bringing up
today
there for instance there was also a
discovery of methane on mars that kind
of peaked a lot of people's interest for
a while
that still has been kind of uh
befuddling scientists about where
exactly that's coming from
so you know whenever we see like a new
bio signature like this it's always like
okay
you know it's never aliens but with this
one it was like
okay well definitely a strong
stronger evidence than we've ever seen
on venus so we've
we all took it very seriously but yes
there's so many times we've been burned
before with discoveries
that we want to make sure that we're
very measured in
in how we describe it and that's why
it's very important to us to talk to
outside sources when
we do get this discovery but i also have
to admit i saw sarah's name
on the uh the list of authors and
sarah's always been such a good source
outside source for me for other studies
so i knew to take this very seriously
when i saw it
um and and i'm glad that i did so one
question that came up a lot uh
in the recent discussion and this this
afternoon was
when are we gonna send a probe there and
actually actually
i think that's how you pronounce this
name actually actually is asking when
are we sending a probe
to venus so sarah you've commanded many
spaceman or space mission of
incredible importance in the test
mission can you talk about
actually how big a deal is this to
actually go to another planet
or just launch something in general and
then what would be the steps what would
be the earliest that someone could
possibly hope to
get direct evidence for this molecule's
existence
well we've read in the news from a few
weeks or months ago that peter beck of
rocket labs
wants to go to venus and always has
apparently since he was a child
go i mean sent his rocket there and he
has a contract to go to the moon
actually so he's able to beef up his
rocket and make it more capable
so probably if peter beck really gets
his way if that's our first chance
and he wants to launch in 2023 which i
think is june 2023
so that may seem like a long time to
some of the people on the chat but trust
me that is like yesterday in the space
world
what would be some of the implications
of sending something there
uh would that would that potentially
have detrimental consequences would it
influence could it affect
the nascent you know embryonic life
forms or whatever might be there
we do have this thing called planetary
protection at least nasa has you know
levels of cleanliness that a spacecraft
has to be
so presumably we'd find a way not to
contaminate it all that said
none of our life here on earth could
survive in the venous atmosphere it's
way too dry
billions of times more acidic than the
most acidic environment on earth
so i don't want to contaminate venus's
atmosphere but if somehow
we accidentally did i wouldn't worry too
much
that's that's usually like you know the
opening line in a science fiction movie
you know
nothing could possibly go wrong but i
think uh lauren you know you point out
you know life finds away the famous you
know quote from the great scientist jeff
gold
goldblum or goldberg and uh in uh
jurassic park classic movie
life finds a way life adapts like i
can't overact as much as him but i love
him
uh but you mentioned you know it's if
you had if i had woken up
well let's say uh last monday not friday
because we're going to talk about some
of the
perils and pitfalls of making an
announcement like this but if i had
woken up last monday
and you he forced me to make a bet i'm
not a betting man but if you have forced
me to make a bet
of where we would find life next it
would be mars and and
you know so what is kind of the uh the
the impetus in the lay person's mind
about
um you know what the probabilities were
to make such a discovery like this and
why is
mars you know always been the focus of
life uh external to the earth
well i think in the course of my
reporting one thing's been very
clear to me that the idea of what makes
a habitable planet
is ever evolving and i think the main
reason that
mars has been such a big focus is
because you know it's it's
of the of the places in the solar system
it's very similar to earth and it's
rocky
and also there's the enticing
possibility of water
liquid water being on its surface in the
past and also
potentially being within the
ground soil now or even in the slope
linear though i think
that is kind of being debated so it's
always been kind of follow the water
but now but as i've been reporting you
know i've been
we've there's been a much bigger focus
on enceladus or in europa with their
subsurface oceans
and now with venus we're we're i mean
this isn't new
there's been researchers talking about
this for since 1967
but you know that the idea that microbes
could live in this environment
isn't exactly a new idea so i think what
what's really been fascinating for me as
a journalist
is seeing just what how we're expanding
our mind when it comes to where to
search for life
in uh the solar system and i think a lot
of
uh astronomers and sarah you can correct
me on this if i'm wrong
are thinking it's it's not a matter of
if but when
it just we don't we just don't know at
what point
it what it what it will look like if it
will be another earth-like planet or if
it could
potentially be you know a subsurface
ocean or
even a world like venus
yeah sarah what can you say about that
in terms of you know the probabilities
just taking some prior beijing prior to
things and
thinking about life versus life by the
way it's not technological life you know
jill tarter is a friend of mine and
a real mentor to many of us astronomers
is
frequently saying you know there's a
huge difference between life and
technological life that we could
communicate with and we've searched
you know the galaxy through the seti
project that she leads and our
friends lead but uh what is the
difference there and and why is it so
uh so challenging or uh thought to be so
hard on a rocky planet like venus
wait can you just ask that again uh why
is it that the you know kind of first
guest for life
uh would be in the um you know on a
rocky planet like mars or
or earth but not in a in the type of
atmospheric form that this potentially
could be represented of
well i think it's exactly what lauren
said that it's followed the water
and venus doesn't have any sign of water
whatsoever
it has the tiniest amount of water mixed
in with the sulfuric acid
droplets
oh we don't hear you brian yeah you
muted
our new virtual world
well while waiting for him to come back
on
well i just wanted to add something i
thought that crossed my mind while you
were
offering it was you know our own earth
we have life in the clouds
and bacteria is upswept from our earth's
surface and it gets up to the cloud
layer
where it freely floats or it's inside
liquid water droplets
but it doesn't stay for long maybe a
week or so before it's rained back down
yeah so the question i had before i got
self-muted hope you can hear me now but
uh is is whether or not this throws the
kind of notion of the habitable zone
that seems to be the
buzzword a lot of times for looking for
external planets sarah so
does this upend our notion of what it
really means to be habitable
well we know about our earth's aerial
biosphere so but yes it certainly
seems to expand our notion of what is
habitable
[Music]
and so thinking back on this let's let's
look at maybe a little bit of the
broader picture
actually before we get to that lauren
when you're writing a a a piece like
this
for a lay audience you have to
communicate the uncertainties that the
scientists are communicating
and actually uh clara susa silva i hope
i'm saying that right sarah's colleague
at mit
as a scientist there uh she was saying
basically i hope bring it on
i mean you know in in a true way bring
it on because we want to be
kind of um we want to look for the most
pernicious effects that could
otherwise cause the signals that we
claim to be seeing
and uh so maybe first lauren how do you
treat the you know i mean if i have to
explain
systematic error analysis to to you know
my my 10 year old
it's very hard to do how do you explain
it to a general audience
so the first thing that i do when i'm
talking to researchers and i'll have to
say
up front clara was a dream to interview
because she
absolutely knew how to explain her work
in a very
um great way to somebody that doesn't
necessarily speak science
um and also it's very clear that she has
a passion for phosphate
because she likes to say like you she
dedicated her 20s to phosphine which i
thought was very charming
but whenever it comes whenever i'm
talking to a scientist and
you know i know that it's easy
especially for me having covered
space and engineers for a very long time
it's easy to kind of get into that
that jargon of what you're talking about
or also some very scientific terms
but sometimes i'll just have to stop
back and step back and say okay
explain to me as if i'm a child or if
i'm you know
in grade school or you know just very
basic or if you were just explaining to
somebody on the street
because oftentimes that gets some of the
best
descriptions that i can then use to
describe to a lay audience
and this time it was very easy to to be
to be able to explain it detection is
also pretty straightforward it's a gas
they were explaining where we find it on
earth and also
why it's so abnormal to find it in a
place like venus
but then at the same time i had to turn
to other scientists who weren't part of
the detection
and talk to them about their you know
misgivings if any about it
but what was really refreshing about
this team too was that when i spoke to
them
clara told me she was like we want
people to come
tell us if we're wrong and that's
exactly what a scientist
should be doing right when it comes to
these kinds of discoveries
the goal is never to scream aliens at
the top it's always to say
okay tell me all the let's exhaust all
of the other options that we can try and
come up with which is what they did in
this paper
and so it was really great to kind of
hear from the scientists the lead
scientists on this paper themselves
we want to open this up to the community
so that they can tell us
give us their other solutions because we
couldn't come up with it
so i think that's really refreshing and
what made covering this so
so fun for me and sarah if you had to
put some of the
commenters or saying things like you
know if you had to guess
the most likely alternative hypothesis
to
life being the culprit here what would
you put your money on i know it's a
it's a hard thing to to suggest right
some equally crazy unknown chemistry
somewhere in venus
surface atmosphere one thing i've
wondered about is are there any
concomitant
tech uh signatures biosignatures that
come with the production
of phosphine you know we we know that
living organisms produce methane
some more than others but but they
produce methane but they also produce
carbon dioxide
and there are other other forms of
perhaps tracers of life what would there
be
in terms of other concomitant uh
signatures
of the life that could make such uh such
a
molecule as phosphine well that we don't
know yet
unfortunately we don't know exactly
which species on earth produces
phosphine
all evidence points to e coli and e coli
can produce a wealth of different gases
so we can't really answer that question
yet
uh so a question from raj luthra is
asking you sarah which would be best
to send a rover a lander or an
atmospheric balloon
to further follow up with this assuming
you could avoid alleviate concerns about
contamination
we definitely would choose balloon the
surface is so hot for life the landers
and
rovers would last a very short time
maybe 20 minutes
an hour at most and the atmosphere is
where it's cool
and the right temperature for life so we
definitely want a balloon that could
last in the atmosphere for days two
weeks to even months
uh and then another question that that i
keep getting
is uh you know if you were to uh if you
were to
follow up in terms of you know
contamination first of all people are
asking
can contamination you know currently
contamination i believe there was one
spacecraft that landed the venera
spacecraft landed at the
soviets flew a long time ago lasted
about 15 minutes
or so on the surface but could there be
other probes that we've sent there i
know we've we've done
some uh landings there but uh could that
be a
possible contamination or is that
completely ruled out like in my opinion
it's completely ruled out
the atmosphere is so dry it would suck
out all water
the hydrosulfuric acid it's so
destructive to any life as we know it
i don't encourage you to do this at home
but if you were to for example put an
ant in concentrated sulfuric acid
it would literally have a siege or die
instantly and within
i don't know 30 seconds or so turn into
a puddle of
kind of black liquid okay so don't try
that at home i'm glad you said that my
19 10 year old
10 year old right well he'd probably
have trouble getting his hands on some
concentrated sulfuric acid
but yeah not knowing him actually he's
going to imagine any of our likes
don't challenge anyone i know that's
right that's right i usually don't have
to put that but i i'll say sarah is a
doctor
okay she is a doctor i listen to her
orders everybody out there all teenagers
out there
um uh so what can you say about an
organism
that could make this uh i mean it's it's
said that it has to be made under
intense
pressure and even the temperature and
pressures on venus aren't enough
for those of us that are completely
ignorant of biology you know how does an
organism make such an interesting thing
at very low pressures and very low
temperatures comparatively
well life does use have life has enzymes
catalysts if you will
to make reaction happen reactions happen
that don't otherwise occur
you know without life so something we
know that that life does typically
and uh i wanted to uh turn a little bit
more back to the you know kind of
personal
and and for the two of you what you
share you know one of you is a scientist
whenever he's a journalist
but on this project it was kind of like
this you know state secret to keep it
secret
and a lot of things you know many ships
or i don't know there's something
betwixt
tongue and lip i don't know there's some
saying i'm sure we could figure out
uh but uh but how do you react to this
how do you decide first of all sarah how
do you decide you've been part of so
many
huge discoveries there's you've got a
fan club in my chat room
as we speak how do you keep these things
embargoed
how do you and why do you keep them
embargo that's that's my first question
well we mainly keep it embargoed and
lauren may have a different opinion but
we want to control the story we want to
make sure that
lauren and the other journalists get a
balanced viewpoint
we're not claiming we found life and
when people start
taking the story and spilling it before
we're ready
they actually can mess the story up for
us so embargoes are good in that way
and what role do journals play in
embargoing i
you know been a part of a couple of
scenarios like this
but what role do the journals have i
mean is there another reason that you
know they want to keep it secret
um well i think it's largely what sarah
was saying is that
they want to make sure that it's
released in kind of a controlled manner
for me personally i just like to have
the time to talk with people and really
understand what
what is being said to me and then make
sure that it's not
because there have been times where i've
received a release
or a journal has given me a story i
think
actually sarah was really helpful in
clarifying a story once that kind of
overhyped
a finding and i was so grateful that i
got to talk to sarah because she was
like no no no
it's not exactly like that and and
having
that gut check is really valuable
because
as a journalist sometimes i can't i
don't really see that right away unless
i talk to an outside source
so for me personally it's just to get
the nuance right and to make sure i get
the facts right and that's really
important to me i know that a lot of
journalists have a lot of different
opinions on the embargo
process and also there's a lot of
it's it's an ever-evolving thing because
people can
post their studies online in advance now
without before they're peer-reviewed and
then
you can also report on them that way we
obviously
um prefer to report when they're
peer-reviewed
because that means this had more eyes on
it that apart from just the study
authors
but yeah for me personally i prefer
embargoes because
it just gives me the time to actually do
the reporting and when i'm scrambling to
write a story or catch up
i feel like that does a disservice to
readers
because it can it's easier for me to
make mistakes and not actually get
the best story that they could possibly
want
and i hope that that's what i was able
to give them today because i had this
a week in advance and it gave me a lot
of time to talk to a lot of people
and sometimes you don't always get that
luxury sometimes you only have a few
days in advance
and those are really scary um but
for this one it was a nice long time
unfortunately
the news kind of leaked but we can get
into that later view
if you can get into it now yeah so so
how did the leak happen
is there you know deep throat what was
it like
well i mean we actually were talking a
few reporter friends of mine were
talking about this ahead of time
because it was such a big discovery that
we were thinking okay it's possible that
it might leak ahead of time and when
that happens
you know the journal can choose to lift
the embargo
and that can be really scary if you
haven't finished your story
because then you have to scramble to get
it up and
i think i've made it clear i don't like
scrambling the the
but this leaked over the weekend a
publication accidentally pub their story
early
they took it down but the damage was
done by then it was all over reddit
and so everybody was talking about it on
sunday and leading up to the
announcement on monday
so we were wondering okay is the journal
going to
you know release or take the embargo up
early they ultimately didn't
and that can be a little frustrating for
us just because it looks like we're late
when the stories are done they're
written they're ready to go
um but we respected the process and
that's
kind of what you do when you do these
embargoes you agree
to you know keep it if that and that's
how it's supposed to work it just these
things happen and it's and it can be
frustrating but
you know the majority of us still stuck
to the embargo and i'm not trying to
pass any judgments for the
publication that did leak it i always
have nightmares of
accidentally pressing publish on a story
before you know before the embargo like
whenever there's a
daylight savings or something we always
are gut-checking ourselves and we're
like okay
make sure you have your embargo times
right because the clock's changed you
know
i definitely empathize with that but
yeah it was it was an interesting
lead up to the announcement because it
was pretty much out there by the time we
hit publish on the story and i think
i think people just want attention for
themselves i could name names here but
i'm not going to
some people just wanted attention and
unfortunately even some professional
colleagues
i don't know if they had been reviewers
or how they had a copy of the paper but
they started
sending it to each other and kind of
making light of that on twitter
yeah i actually heard about it last week
from one of my kids
and and i was like i hadn't heard and
i actually wasn't as in the know as my
as my kid was
you know i was like ah that's impossible
you know we spent i set the lander there
it melted
but you know it is true that there have
been many cases actually the discovery
of the cosmic microwave background
radiation by penzias and wilson was
leaked
about a month before the actual uh you
know kind of press release went forward
and it's stimulated the press release
from bell labs
because of a new york times reporter
that was friendly with with
bob dickey and other people at princeton
and potentially a reviewer who was
involved so it's it's
certainly a common thing that takes
place sarah you were saying before
we actually went live that it seemed as
if
you know it was just kind of uh magical
or perhaps and that's not the right word
but
it was there was something amazing about
the time dilation the distortion of time
that took place because
you guys have been talking about this
for for three years two or three years
you know presumably on a daily basis and
it's occupied all your
daily thoughts but um but then the media
and the public got it and in 12 hours
they're
just going crazy what has that
experience been like for you as a
scientist
well it's been pretty amazing in fact
i've been kind of eavesdropping on this
email list i'm on where people are
violently disparaging the discovery and
you can kind of see some of them kind of
coming around because there's another
person will say actually that is
possible or actually you're wrong about
this statement
whereas we had years many years because
when i first got involved with phosphine
with it
i connected to our team lead professor
jane greaves team i was incredibly
skeptical
honestly i just thought it was nothing i
thought it was gonna go away so many
times
and so but we had so many years to work
through it try something try something
again
and yeah they have one day to do this
they've had or
as of yesterday without even any real
information hours so in some ways maybe
i'm not surprised people are taking it
so badly
and you also were saying you know that
jane grieves had gotten really
a lot of uh you know had a lot of
courage to go out
so far on a limb i think um somebody was
she changed her
twitter handle to dr phosphane or
something like that
uh somebody did maybe it was claire or
her i'm not sure but
professor grieves she's a radio
astronomer she studies um
things actually outside of our solar
system and for some reason she decided
to
turn the instruments on on venus and to
search she wanted to purposely search
for signs of life on venus and she
diligently researched
in scientific publications and i'm
shocked at this because
we also did that on my team and led by
in this case dr william baines and dr
yanish pitkowski
and we have a whole series of obscure
papers well jane found some of these
same obscure papers
and she took this information and
proposed to
to a radio telescope the jcmt james
clerk maxwell telescope to make this
kind of crazy attempt what was the role
of alma is that the radio
element of it yes well first jane used
the jcmt and she found a signal of
phosphine surprise
as anyone but it wasn't really terribly
strong
but it was enough to propose for time on
alma a more powerful telescope
and that's about the time when my team
connected with her
and this is a question for lauren um
from randolph klein he says only the
phosphine j equals one to zero
transition was detected
and are there other transition detected
these are quantum mechanical transitions
i i think actually this is for sarah
are there other transitions of phosphine
that could be
detectable in the visible or in the alma
bands
so in the alma bands sadly that's the
only one now normally
when you make a detection you want to
see more than one line
it's like not even getting a complete
fingerprint
so we regret that we can only detect
that one line in the alma bends
now phosphine absorbs in other places it
absorbs the infrared the near infrared
and even the mid
kind of emitted infrared and we do we
have some data from
the irtf the infrared nasa and it's the
infrared telescope facility in hawaii
where we have
some team members have been proposing to
use other telescopes including the
airborne sofia observatory to try to
search but phosphine is very weak
infrared
spectral bands so it's going to be tough
so i want to talk uh naturally these
things bring up implications beyond the
scientific and maybe even to you know
ultimate issues type questions so i want
to ask each one of you
start maybe with with lauren uh what do
you feel are some of the longer lasting
implications both of the findings
announced today
but also of the long-term prospects for
looking for life
outside of or signs of life outside of
the earth
i think for me it goes back to what i
was saying earlier it just opens up our
understanding of what makes a habitable
world
and i think that's really key because
there have been a lot of times that
especially with exoplanets and the more
exoplanets that we discover
the habitable zone is always kind of
hyped up as this place where
you know life can thrive on other
planets
and we're learning that that's very
nuanced right especially when you're
an exoplanet you know around a
small dwarf star you know or you're very
close to the star
and the the habitable zone there is a
very different place in the habitable
zone
where earth is right now so yeah for me
i think this discovery just says that we
scientists are getting really creative
in terms of where
we can look for life in other planets
and then also the implications are okay
so what are we going to do about it
and i know that a lot of people within
this
the science community have been a little
sad that venus has gone largely
unignored
compared to mars and compared to the
other planets in the solar system
so i think this will like i said in the
story raise venus's clout
in terms of places to go and it might be
a little more helpful i mean you saw
nasa administrator jim bridenstine tweet
today
about the discovery i think that will
you know pay dividends
because nasa is paying attention and the
community is paying attention and so i
think that could go a long way
and perhaps you know green lighting
place
you know more more missions to go to
venus which i think would be really cool
to see
yeah and sarah what do you make of the
um
you know broader impact so to speak the
implications of this and why it's so
um so intoxicating to the lay person and
even to the scientists
people love science fiction movies
tv books and so just the thought of
finding an
alien life form so close to home is just
amazing i'm with lauren though this will
raise venus's profile
i always think of venus you know what
sometimes called earth's sister planet
because it's about the same size about
the same mass
i always like to think of venus as the
neglected sibling
i know a lot of it's friends i'm not
sure if it's true in your family but
sometimes there's just that one kid
that's just always ignored
so this is going to bring venus back up
back to where it should be
and they also want to add to you know
it's been such a tough year for a lot of
people and
this is such a nice thing to think about
you know contemplating our place in the
universe
that is always going to be something
that makes us
feel small but precious and
i think it's just a nice bright spot and
and
you know i hate to say it our story
didn't do as well as you know other kind
of tragic news that's out there right
now
but it did make it an impact and i think
that's
important for people to kind of take a
step back from all the other things that
are happening
and just kind of contemplate their their
place in the universe and i think that's
really
beautiful yeah i think the journalist
motto is going to change from
it bleeds it leads to it breathes it
leads maybe
maybe this can make a big difference my
last couple of questions because i know
you guys have been busy all day long i
want to respect your time this is from
neurostream
and uh they are sharing a comment that
says
after sharing your findings publicly
today sarah are new opportunities
presenting themselves for further study
in-depth follow-up and what's next for
you sarah
well nothing new as of today has
presented itself i think the world is
just
digesting the news i think as lauren
pointed out the head of nasa speaking
about
about venus is pretty important what's
next for me well
i'm continuing to work on exoplanets and
the search for life that's still
most dear to my heart but i'm also
pursuing venus
and trying to figure out how we can send
a small focused mission there
oh wow so a young beginning grad student
that could
potentially play a role in a future
mission to venus
and like you said yes it's the child
there's a motto i think that maybe my
gran my mother told me you know you're
only as happy as your least happy child
well now hopefully we'll make venus a
little bit happier as a child of the
solar system
and get it the attention that that she
deserves
um so the last i just want to point out
a couple of things that
uh that resources where people can find
stuff i put links in the
in the description box for this video
about
the press release from mit and some
links to the
cloud life venus cloudslife.com which is
a website
that has been set up for more
information this is by sarah's group
and her collaborators you can find more
of lauren's work
on the verge and elsewhere and we
really enjoy your writing and i hope
you'll keep it up you have a very very
unique ability to take very complex
subjects and make them understandable
are there any other things you'd like to
talk about before we sign off for today
sarah is there anything else
you'd like to mention or just for people
to remember the balanced view we're not
claiming we found life
we are claiming we found a gas that
doesn't belong and we have a lot of work
ahead of us to see where that takes us
very good and
lauren anything final words from you or
got things we might have missed skipped
over
just kind of adding to that and i tried
to say that in the story as well i think
that's equally as exciting it's
something strange is happening you know
it may not be life but it's still
something cool that we don't understand
and so no matter what this is going to
to you know
bring about really cool findings and i'm
so excited to follow it as a journalist
and and see what what news and
follow-ups come
come my way well that's really uh really
fascinating we're seeing you know final
comments uh
people wondering how they can donate to
venus because they feel so bad
i'm not kidding i don't know if there's
i think i'm my venmo i can put out my
venmo maybe
sarah can put out hers i want to thank
both of you guys so much for
doing so much to educate the public but
also educate the scientists because this
has been a really
fascinating well-attended live stream
and i do want to wish you both the best
of luck and i hope we can be in touch
sarah i'd love to have you on to discuss
your wonderful new book
uh it's really so meaningful you're such
an inspiration and a mentor to people
and
friend and so forth around the world but
you're an inspiration and i'd love to
have you on the
impossible podcast and lauren likewise
you're always welcome back and
keep up the wonderful work thank you
so much